Hey everyone.  We're be taking a look at trade offs in labor and capital markets.
And what this does is it builds off of what we covered in our previous video where we looked at firms in the long run in a competitive market and we saw that those firms tend towards mean reversion.
That is, they tended towards normal economic profits.
That is, they didn't have a positive economic profit.
They had an economic profit that was zero.
Now they still could have a positive accounting profit, but what we saw was that assets are going to continue to move in different ways and that also works in labor and capital.
So we're going to be looking at how labor and capital move through a few different mechanisms.
Let's go ahead and jump into it.
Now imagine you're a software developer who is currently living in Nashville and you're currently earning $96,925 per year.
But you discover that in San Diego, developers are earning similar level at a similar level as you are earning approximately $147,182.
Now these are, these numbers are from glassdoor.com so these are accurate numbers.
But what might happen?
Well, you might see people get into their car and apply for jobs and move over to San Diego.
So what we're going to start to see is more developers are going to be moving towards San Diego seeking that higher pay.
So the supply of labor is going to increase over there and the supply of labor in Nashville is going to decrease.
So what you're going to see is the developers in those respective cities can now afford to pay people in San Diego less and they can afford to pay people in Nashville more.
So what's actually taking place here, we're going to start to see the salaries equalize over time.
This exemplifies the indifference principle here.
When workers are mobile, wage differences for similar jobs in different locations, they're going to tend to equalize over time and it's going to account for different factors like cost of living living and job desirability.
So the indifference principle is a lot like what we saw with mean reversion and tending towards a long run equilibrium with zero economic profits in that those salaries are going to eventually equalize out or there's going to be something that this creates an undesirable level that people don't want to move for that slightly higher wage.
All right, now we also have this example here.
In the 1990s, what we saw was a shift in manufacturing from northern states down to southern states.
So that also meant that demand for labor increased in southern States, while demand for labor in northern states and manufacturing, that is decreased.
So your supply of labor and demand for labor are going to have to match up and create new job opportunities.
So here I've selected four states.
Two from the north, two from the south.
We have Alabama and Georgia, Michigan and Ohio.
And so prior to the 1990s, what I've already said, manufacturing is more heavily dominated in the north.
And then manufacturers started moving to the south.
Labor was cheaper, but as the supply of labor shrunk and the demand for labor increased, so what we saw was pay also changed.
So over time, what we've started to see is wage growth amongst these states has more or less normalized.
And so you can see that these growth rates each year are pretty much in line with one another.
So again, we see this indifference principle in action.
Now let's talk a little bit about compensating differentials.
So imagine you have markets pushing wages towards equality.
Okay, so why then does a sanitation worker.
Why do some jobs pay more?
Why does a sanitation worker and a retail sales clerk, both of these have similar educational requirements?
That is, you don't necessarily need a college degree to be in either one of these.
Why don't these two jobs require that don't require a college degree.  Why do.
Why does one make over 20,000 more than the other?
The sanitation worker making $55,990 per year, the retail sales clerk making $32,460 a year.
Now, these numbers are averaged.
Then they come from the Bureau of Labor Statistics.
This is as of 2024.
So these numbers are accurate.
And so we have to ask ourselves again, no.
The same amount of educational requirement, but yet one makes $20,000 more.
Why is this the case?
I mean, the answer is simple.
It's compensating differentials here.
This just means that some jobs pay more, not because they were going to require more skill.
It's just because they involve some unpleasant or risky condition.
I mean, imagine being a sanitation worker.
That sounds very unpleasant to me.
Versus being a retail sales clerk when you're more going to be in an office job.
So here we know sanitation work is more physically demanding.
It's smelly and exposes workers to hazards, whereas that's not necessarily going to occur in the retail sales clerk position.
So that's why we need to offer them higher wages to attract people, despite all the downsides that go into that job.
Here are some other roles.
The Alaskan king crab Fisherman, very popular TV series and things like that.
Over $100,000 a year.
In many cases very dangerous.
There has one of the highest occupational fatality rates.
And so you have to compensate people for that extra risk.
Night shift nurses, night shift nurses often make 10 to 15% more than day shift nurses do.
And that's simply because it's not a desirable position to have.
So you have to compensate the person for that level of undesirableness.
And then underwater welders here, what we're looking at, between that five plus years experience, they can make between 75,000 per year.
Again, this is a job that's pretty risky.
You're underwater, so you have to be able to scuba dive, you have to be able to weld.
But compare that to the average welder.
So what you might find is that there is some difference there between these types of jobs.
So here, these are all examples of compensating differentials.
Higher wages have to be offered to compensate the people for those undesirable job attributes like risk inconvenience or just straight up unpleasantness.
All right, so let's move now to our capital.
We covered labor and how we have compensating differentials.
The indifference principle.
Let's now turn to capital and the trade offs involved there, the mobility that goes into it.
So investors here, they have to decide how they want to allocate their capital across the spectrum of assets.
So here we're looking at low risk and low return options, like bonds to high risk and high return ones like something perhaps like Bitcoin or other stocks that are very risky or currencies that are very risky.
This trade off here is captured by the concept of what we call the risk return relationship.
Higher expected returns are generally, generally required to compensate for higher levels of risk.
All right, so what we're going to be looking at is this additional return demanded by investors for holding a riskier asset, one that's above the risk free rate.
And we call this through the risk premium.
So here we have risk premiums equal to er, little I minus RF prime, where E R little I is the expected return of the Asset I&RF prime is the risk free rate, typically the risk free rate.  You look at U.S.
treasuries as a way to determine what the risk free rate happens to be.
So what we're going to see is during periods of uncertainty, like if you go back to the 2008 financial crisis that we had, or you look at the COVID shot, the pandemic that we had in 2020, capital is going to be flowing out of equities into safe haven assets again like the U.S.  treasury bond.
So that flight of safety that you see increases the demand for Treasuries, so that pushes their prices up and their yields are going to go down.
So again, as more people are demanding these Treasuries, their prices go up but their yields go down.
This is supply and demand and this is what we see in these financial markets.
Here is a graph showing what happened during the 2008 financial crisis.
So what we have is an inverse relationship between bond prices and yields.
And that's fundamental principle and finance.
And then investors have to decide how to allocate that capital across that spectrum of assets.
Again, do they want to go low risk, low return, high risk or high return?
All right, so again we can see how this chart illustrates.
In 2008 financial crisis we started with a higher yield, but as people started to move more of the assets towards Treasuries, that yield began to decrease.
They wanted less risk as compared to be involved in the stock market at that time.
Now you can also look at the average annual returns by some different investment types.
These are a ten year horizon.
We've got the ten year treasury bond, the S&P 500 and Bitcoin.
So the ten year treasury there is about 4.3%.
Over ten years the S and P is going to be around 10% and then Bitcoin 80%, it's a little bit more than 80% I believe, but on a 10 year annualized basis it's around 80%.
So we do see some risk and return trade off here.
If you go with that treasury bond, it's going to offer safety, stability, but your returns are just very modest.
All right, if you go with the S&P 500, you have a little bit more risk involved in the S&P 500 you have, but you do have a broad exposure there to the equities.
If you go with the index itself.
But you do get higher returns, much better than what you got with the 10 year Treasury.
All right, now move on to Bitcoin while delivering these explosive returns.  Right?
I mean if you look at it, 80%, a little bit more than that, it's extremely volatile and it's speculative, but you still get that high, high return.
But you have the high risk.
So these differences here, these differences here in return reflect the varying levels of risk premium that each asset must offer to attract investment.
Now for example, if the risk free rate is the treasury, the 10 year treasury, there's then that is 4.3%.
Now the S&P average 10% over this time so 10% of the expected return from the asset, that is the index you're investing in.
In the s and P500, that's 10% minus the 4.3% in the risk free rate.
That tells you you get an equity risk premium of 5.7%.
Basically what that says, we need almost 6% as investors we need almost 6% extra to tolerate the stock market risk.
Otherwise if we didn't like that we were risk averse, we would move back into Treasuries.
Okay, now look at Bitcoin.
Now that's going to be a massive risk premium.
And we have to remember though, this isn't free money in Bitcoin.
Although it looks very nice, there's a lot of volatility that goes in there.
Drawdowns can happen up to 60% or more.
And so most investors here wouldn't touch it without the potential for huge upside, high risk, high reward.
So that's the risk premium there in action.
This is also why portfolios are usually diversified.
Do you go to your financial advisor, they're going to want you to diversify your portfolio.
Some in Treasuries or bonds, some in the stock market, some in metals, things like that.
So this is the modern portfolio theory thing suggests investors can combine assets with different risk return profiles to optimize their performance and minimize any unnecessary exposure.
All right, so bottom line here is that capital we don't want to chase returns blindly.
We want to look at what we have and evaluate our risk.
So if demand this chase or again not we don't chase it blindly, but this chase it demands a reward for the risk.  Okay.
And over time, only assets that offer fair compensation for uncertainty will attract long term investment.
All right, so let's pull it off all here together.
Trade offs rule the market.
In long run mobility of capital labor are going to erase any unearned advantages.
We're going to see that as labor moves from lower valued use to higher value use capital, same thing.
Higher pay usually comes with a trade off though there's more risk, less convenience and a lot of more effort to get into that higher payoff.
So we know there's no such thing as a free lunch, right?
Compensation here aligns with the trade offs individuals are willing to make.
Let's do some key takeaways here.
The indifference principle.
Wage differences for similar jobs tend to equalize over time due to labor mobility compensating differentials.
Jobs with undesirable attributes offer often offer higher pay to attract workers.
The risk premium investors require high returns to compensate for increased risk.
And then lastly, market dynamics in both labor, labor and capital markets, we see these trade offs determine compensation and returns and that is it.
Hope you enjoyed.